what if we dropped Godzilla from space
funny quest
and no we aren't talking about
spacegodzilla so like how in the world
does that even
makes sense and why would we even want
to drop this humungous Thailand all the
way from space a quick recap or we can
say a quickie on monster was Godzilla
facts that he stands at around 3 on of
93 feet or 120 metres in height
weighing nearly a hundred thousand tons
and he is a hundred thousand cubic
meters in volume which makes the big G
around one ton per cubic meter in
density so yeah now that we are done
with that let's go back to a scene from
the fight between Godzilla and King
Ghidorah in the final sequence of the
king of the monsters movie they were
bought in a stalemate after so much
fighting when finally ki Dora got a
powerup
by consuming the entire electric supply
to the city of Boston
he then got the upper hand with his tree
heads two days to limbs and wings he
constricted of G man and flew him up up
to the lower reaches of the atmosphere
and that just releases him for an
ultimate power bomb yeah wrestling
reference so the G man burns up as he
crashes down into the city and levels
many city blocks but that was just
godzilla falling from the upper
troposphere just above the clouds and
nowhere near terminal velocity and even
though he was burning like an asteroid
the force of impact was likely less than
a kiloton although it should have been
more but was downplayed as there was
still human protagonists in the near
vicinity so now that we know what
happens if we drop Godzilla from the
lower atmosphere let's try to imagine
what would be the consequences of
letting him freefall from outer space
and right into the same city ok let's
say we don't carry him up there but then
Ghidorah does the job for us to answer
this question we have to take another
quick look into impact events of
asteroids and meteorites when large
objects in factories your planet such as
the earth there can be significant
physical and biospheric consequences
though atmospheres mitigate many surface
impacts through atmospheric entry still
then a few large objects do make it true
and create gigantic craters and an
explosion of tremendous levels
meteoroids have a pretty big size range
they include any space debris bigger
than a molecule and smaller than about
fear and 30 feet are 100 meters wide
spaced every bigger than that it's
considered an asteroid so we can
consider Godzilla in space again not
space Godzilla so Godzilla in space as
an asteroid as he has surpassed a
benchmark in size meteoroids enter the
atmosphere at extremely high speeds of
seven to 45 miles per second or 11 to 72
kilometers per second Earth's atmosphere
on the upper hand is full of matter
which creates a great deal of friction
on a traveling object this friction
generates enough heat up to three
thousand degrees Fahrenheit or 1650
degrees Celsius to raise the meteorites
surface to its boiling point so the
meteoroid is vaporized layer by layer
but still the larger objects do survive
the upper atmosphere and due to the
intense changes in heat and pressure
they end up in Airbus which are very
powerful explosions comparable to the
most powerful nuclear weapons larger
objects survive the Airbus mode and come
crashing down into the earth and create
a catastrophe
sometimes wiping out a majority of the
terrestrial ecosystem and causing an
extinction-level event so can Godzilla
create such an impact or would he end up
in an air force mode we can say for
certain that due to his size and weight
he will not burn up and vaporize on
re-entry okay let's put two presumptions
first number one Godzilla will not
vaporize layer by layer and become
smaller during reentry as we have seen
him in his burning form melting stubborn
metal that were close to by number two
his velocity would be close or equal to
media's and meteorites entering the
earth in the range of seven to 45 miles
per second or 11 to 72 kilometers per
second
let's put 17 so based on research on
impact events we have found out that the
biggest meteorite that will burn up
during reentry is below four meters in
diameter while between four and ninety
meters or thirteen and 300 feet they
usually usually end up in an air
mode between 1 kiloton and 28 megatons
so an impactor with a diameter of 100
meters or 330 feet falling at a velocity
of 17 kilometers per second and at a 45
degree angle will cause a gradual
release of 45 megatons during re-entry
burn up when it crashes the explosion
will be around 3.4 megatons somewhat in
the range of today's thermonuclear
warhead that is due to them losing mass
as they burn up layer by layer the
closest match to Godzilla size is a 130
meter impactor and let's say it is
falling at the same speed and angle
during reentry it will gradually release
close to 103 megatons and due to its
larger size a bigger fragment would
actually hit the surface with a force of
30 1.4 megatons and creating a crater of
2 kilometers in diameter but taking
presumption number one that as Godzilla
will not burn up layer by layer during
reentry this would make the G man's
force way more than 30 1.4 megatons and
put a crater of 2 kilometers since more
than half of the impactors burn up and
leaves only half the size of the
original measurement so Godzilla's more
equivalent impactor size would be a 250
meter diameter rock that will crash down
to earth with only half its size that is
1 and 25 meters in diameter touching
down and thankfully we have found out
from good sources that such an impactor
would release close to 600 megatons
during the crash onto earth and creating
a crater of nearly 4 kilometers or 2.5
miles wide so there you go
if we drop Godzilla from space he would
crash down with a force of 600 megatons
or equivalent to 12 Tsar Bomba
in case some of you don't know what a
Tsar Bomba is it is humanity's largest
ever bomb a hydrogen bomb exploding with
a force of 50 megatons but what would
happen to the city of Boston so just
once our bomber is enough to totally
level a circle area of 48 kilometers or
30 miles wide just to one would wipe off
the entire city of Boston and its bay
and also create serious damages up to
Rhode Island in the south
so Godzilla's crash of 600 megatons
would most likely destroy everything
within a hundred and fifty kilometers or
a hundred miles radius up to Connecticut
if he fell in Boston and then serious
damages up to New York City to the
southwest and Canada to the north sorry
hey so that brings us to the end of the
video do like share and subscribe